databases can scale up in two ways  vertically means the database lives on a  single physical machine and is given  more CPU cores and RAM to handle more  traffic and throughput the problem is  that a machine can only get so big the  most high traffic apps in the world  often use nosql databases like redis and  Cassandra that can scale horizontally  with sharding data is distributed across  multiple machines that can handle read  write operations in parallel closer to  the end user what's confusing though is  that it's still possible for a database  to completely fit its pants which is  referred to in the industry as database  sharding